so we've been talking a lot about family
so did you have um you know the
relationship with your mother how you
have with your children
yes I'm very very close to my mother but
not the kind of relationship I think
that I have with my kids I don't know
it's just it's just generational my mom
the same like she's like it's so funny
me and my sister are very open with our
kids and we'll talk about anything but
my mom I think it's a generation thing
because she will not she is like I don't
feel like we need to talk about this to
discuss it and I'm like what so that's
it must be a generation thing but was
there any advice you remember getting
from your mom though because you're so
young like starting out was there any
advice she kind of gave you she always
said to me you make the most of yourself
Catherine because you never know when
you're going to meet the president of
the United States okay cut to like I'm
living in Wales in a village I was never
gonna the president is not gonna be
walking down on my street anytime soon
so I don't know an odd thing yeah what
she was talking about and I think it was
from the Kennedy years you know I mean
Camelot from Britain I mean America in
the politics and the president was that
kind of Jackie oh and you know you know
yeah so anyway she always said that to
me always and KATU
funny enough the Kennedy Honors we were
just this past week I was helping give
Sean his Kennedy Honors and I was in
Washington with Michael and that morning
he said guess what they're putting the
decorations up a friend of Michaels who
works within the White House the Clinton
White House said we can go and see them
put up the decorations I went up my
street all right well it's not with me
getting my hair and makeup done because
I'm going to get ready for the big event
so I threw on my sweatpants
no makeup oh no they're wet baseball cap
and I'm standing there do you want to
see the Oval Office like oh yeah no yeah
anyway I'm in the Oval Office I will
look out the window and there's Bill
Clinton in a like Lumberjack shirt and
blue jeans chipping golf balls and I go
and then he turned and then he's walking
towards me and all I kept thinking was
my mother
most of yourself
and he's walking towards me you never
know
and I'm like hi like not trying to make
contact I probably had sleep in my eyes
you know like Hello uh anyway I wish you
would have been like it only goes up
from here yeah yeah I scrub up well you
know but uh anyway it was one of those
wonderful my mum I love her
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]